also ich finde ich finde Maurice ist ein
sehr guter Verkoster
essen kann ich
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
mein Team hat sich mal wieder einen
Cheesecake gewünscht und zwar mit
Kinderschokolade ein kinderschokoladen
Cheesecake und der wird jetzt zubereitet
ganz ohne Backofen das heißt es ist ein
no bake cake den ihr zu Hause ganz
einfach schnell mit wenigen Zutaten
zubereiten könnt ich habe jetzt hier
schon mal die Zutaten für den Boden und
für die Creme und später kommen nur noch
zwei Zutaten für Deko dazu aber das sind
im Prinzip dann auch Sahne und
Kinderschokolade das heißt im Prinzip
sind es wirklich nur eins zwei drei vier
fünf sechs Zutaten daraus besteht dieser
Kuchen also fangen wir direkt mal an
dafür verwende ich 140g Butter 200 g
Butterkekse für die Füllung also die
Cheesecake Masse 100g Sahne 200g
Kinderschokolade
300g Frischkäse noch mal 200 g Sahne und
seiner paar zum steif schlagen
ich gebe jetzt wie bei allen die Butter
entweder in die Mikrowelle zum Schmelzen
oder in den Topf das mache ich jetzt
hier mal
bei niedriger Stufe damit die Butter
nicht spritzt
heißt bei mir Stufe 4 4 von 9 und die
Kekse werden zerkleinert entweder im
Mixer im mit dem aus Holzstab ihr könnt
ein wacker dafür nehmen ihr könnten
Mörser dafür nehmen also hauptsache sie
werden zerkleinert
ich nehme jetzt den Mixer
und ich gucke mal was ich so an Kekse
noch im Vorratsschrank habe falls wir
offene Kekse haben die nehme ich dann
immer so mit dazu so alle Reste rein und
fertig manchmal ändert sich dann die
Buttermenge je nach keksorte also hier
bei den Butterkeksen passt es so jetzt
im Verhältnis aber wenn ich etwas
fettigere Kekse habe dann kommt auch
manchmal ein bisschen weniger Butter
rein aber das merkt man dann immer
[Musik]
zwei die tanzen einfach in der Mitte
die wollen sich nicht sehr klein lassen
[Musik]
jetzt eigentlich kann ich sogar schon so
lange die Butter schmilzt die Sahne
aufkochen in einem anderen Topf denn das
wird jetzt quasi eine Ganache die aber
mit in den Frischkäsefüllung kommt also
in die Cheesecake Masse
das heißt
ich nehme einen Topf und koche jetzt
kurz die Sahne auf und solange
vertrödeln wir die Zeit auch nicht
sondern nutzen die Zeit schon mal um die
Schokolade
dann rechnet jetzt ein bisschen mehr mit
ein dann könnt ihr auch was wegmachen
aber so brauchen wir schon die vollen
200g
und später noch für den Chip und später
für die Deko
und sobald die Sahne gekocht hat könnte
den Herd ausschalten und die Kleinen
kinderschokoladenriegelchen mit
dazugeben
[Musik]
die Butter ist geschmolzen die gebe ich
jetzt zu den keksbröteln dazu es wird
kurz eingerührt
[Musik]
am Ende hat die Masse eine Konsistenz
wie ja eigentlich wie nasser Sand und
ihr nehmt euch jetzt eine Springform
oder eben einen Tortenring ich habe das
jetzt hier in den Springformboden da
verrutscht nichts aber ohne Springform
Boden geht es auch auf einem
tortenritter ganz glatt da kommt die
Masse jetzt rein und wird schon flach
gedrückt entweder mit einem Glas oder
z.B auch mit einer burgerpresse
[Musik]
der Boden ist perfekt den stelle ich
kurz zur Seite hier habe ich noch die
schöne kinderschokoladencreme die Fülle
ich jetzt schon mal um in eine große
Rührschüssel damit sie bisschen auskühlt
und den Boden stelle ich solange in den
Kühlschrank und sind etwa 5 Minuten ist
die Creme auch soweit dass ich dann eben
die sahne Creme zubereiten kann aber
dann haben wir schon mal den Boden und
die Cheesecake Masse fertig
die Kinder Schokoladenmasse ist jetzt
schön kalt der Boden steht noch im
Kühlschrank dann nehme ich jetzt den
Frischkäse den rühre ich aber oder ich
zerdrücken so ein bisschen aber ihr
könnte nämlich vorher kurz einmal
durchrühren dann wenn ihr den jetzt so
mit so einem zu der
kinderschokoladencreme gibt und noch
nicht vorher geschmeidig wird kann es
schon sein dass ein paar Brötchen drin
hat das wollen wir nicht
und jetzt kommt es hier rein und wird
schön eingerührt
und wer den Geschmack von Frischkäse
einfach so gar nicht mag ich meine es
ist ein Cheesecake da kommt Frischkäse
rein der kann alternativ auch gerne
Quark nehmen
oder Mascarpone das Halten italienischer
Frischkäse aber der schmeckt nicht so
wie
quasi der deutsche traditionelle
Frischkäse jetzt kurz verrühren
dann kommt die Sahne langsam dazu
und dann die Creme schön miteinander
steif schlagen
ihr müsst wirklich drauf achten dass die
kinderschokoladencreme die wir am Anfang
geschmolzen haben mit der Sahne dass die
schön kalt ist denn sonst kann es
passieren dass ich die Sahne drin das
heißt dies die muss kalt sein Sahne muss
kalt sein Frischkäse muss kalt sein und
dann ist alles super
und ich habe quasi die Creme vom Rand so
nach unten dann sieht auch später alles
schön sauber aus das sind so die Details
die sind immer ausmachen
einmal abdecken und ab in den
Kühlschrank für mindestens ein bis zwei
Stunden
jetzt ist der Kuchen gut durchgekühlt
und ich habe jetzt hier noch mal eine
Ganache hergestellt also einfach 100
Gramm Sahne aufgekocht 200 Gramm
Kinderschokolade mit reingegeben und
dann eben gut auskühlen lassen hier ist
die Ganache die sitzt nur noch
zimmerwarm tatsächlich die gieße ich
jetzt hier drauf und lass den Ring aber
drumherum dann kommt der Kuchen noch mal
in den Kühlschrank
[Musik]
das ist jetzt schön verteilt der Kuchen
kommt noch mal in den Kühlschrank damit
ich gerne fest wird und die Glas so
schön anzieht die zieht vielleicht nicht
komplett an also vielleicht bleibt sie
so ein bisschen halb flüssig aber das
ist völlig okay aber mein Kühlschrank
habe ich noch Kinderschokolade und ein
paar Krams für die Dekoration denn ich
bin jetzt fertig der Kuchen muss nur
noch kühl dann kann das dekoriert werden
ja du darfst ein bisschen waschen
[Musik]
die Torte ist gekühlt jetzt kann ich es
hier mal rauslösen
[Musik]
irgendwie erinnerte mich optisch total
an den Polo tsunamic cake weil die
Glasur so ein bisschen halbflüssig ist
aber dann doch recht fest anzieht
[Musik]
dann probieren wir doch mal dieses
Prachtstück mit einem Prachtstück
nicht gut doch ja das war doch so der
Murat wollte sagen wie sagt man
eigentlich so das Haus brennt ne die
Hütte brennt
die Hütte brennt okay und dann sagt der
Murat der Baum brennt und wer ist dann
noch mal zum Fenster gerannt und hat
geguckt
das ist der Kinder Cheesecake
das sieht sehr lecker
muss ich nicht mal probieren ich weiß
dass es lecker ist Schokolade
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
voll lecker
super lecker
sehr cremig das richtig cremig
ich finde super und ich muss zugeben ich
bin nicht nee warte
dann mache ich mich alt ich würde sagen
als ich jünger war habe ich gern
Kinderschokolade gegessen aber dann
bedeutet das jetzt alt bin
ich liebe Kinderschokolade
aber vor ein paar Jahren noch
liebte ich sie sehr und jetzt ist sie
mittlerweile zu süß ich kann
Kinderschokolade nur in Kombination mit
Chips essen mit Chips ja und zwar
Kinderschokolade im Kühlschrank schöne
kalte Temperatur dann nimmst du den die
rechte Hand in die linke Hand die
Chipstüte aber die Paprika die original
Chips frisch
und dann musst du einmal kurz abbeißen
und dann schnell die Chips hinterher und
dann beides so zusammen
okay wie wäre es damit wir machen mal
ein Format Sallys komische
Essgewohnheiten und mein Team darf diese
Essgewohnheiten probieren
also Kinderschokolade mit Chips Nutella
mit Salami Nutella mit Feta
Nutella
Frischkäse mit Marmelade
Lasagne
Nutella mit Butter oben drauf
doch glaub's mir ich schreib mir mal
meine komischen Dinger da auf meine
komischen Essgewohnheiten
ja
ich frage mich überlege gerade ob ich
irgendwelche Essgewohnheiten habe die so
abnormal sind aber ich es einfach zu
viel das ist das einzige Problem bei mir
aber sonst
ein paar komische Essgewohnheiten wo
andere sagen
aber ich liebe es meine Lehrerin hat mal
Chips mit Tzatziki gegessen aber das ist
ja noch in Ordnung
und ich habe mal aus versehen was
gemacht du kennst ja Langosch vom
Weihnachtsmarkt so diese frittierten
Teigtaschen von Max gelernt ja und die
gibt's mit Knoblauchcreme und dann gibt
es die aber auch mit süßem Rahmen und
Zimt Zucker Apfelmus und so und ich habe
die hier mal zubereitet und dann hat
mein Fotograf damals da marius hat aus
Versehen verkauft das heißt der hat die
Knoblauchcreme genommen und hat dann
aber süß getoppt mit äh Zimtzucker und
das war so lecker oh mein Gott das war
richtig lecker also
Knoblauchcreme mit Zimtzucker auf einem
Langosch auch sehr gut ja für weitere
Geschmacksexplosionen folgt einfach
meinen Kanälen und abonniert diesen
Kanal gerne und schreibt gerne eure
Geschmacksexplosion auch mal in die
Kommentare denn ich probiere gerne Neues
aus und ich bin da schon so ein Bild da
Freak der so alles einmal durch das
testet das ist eine Idee
aber
cool also
probiert das Rezept gerne aus der ist
wirklich wahnsinnig cremig und das ist
jetzt keine komische
Geschmackskombination sondern wirklich
einfach nur das echt lecker
das finde ich super ja die Tragödie ist
dass ich zwei davon gemacht habe weil
ich eins für eine real aufgenommen habe
und eins für dieses Video und die tragöd
ist jetzt quasi wir haben jetzt eine
komplette Torte hier für Studio Team und
das ist kein Problem
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss und
schreibt mir gerne welche Torte oder
welche Süßigkeiten
also ich find ich finde Maurice ist ein
sehr guter verkosten
Essen gar nicht
[Musik]